so curious how you financed all three of
your feature films were they different
situations each time okay how did I
well every feature film that I've done
has gotten finance differently because
it's what you do when you get there it's
sort of like there's no plan if I was
independently wealthy or had some sort
of you know whatever there's no there's
no plan it's just it's what you do at
the time with 10 till noon we raised
money through traditional investors you
know we burned through a lot of favors
and we burned through all our money
people with official rejection we ended
up self-financing the whole movie it was
it was but you know but a lot of that
piggybacked 10 till noon so and that was
we were able to do pretty cheaply we
deferred a lot of money in that film so
yeah we were lit that way with favor we
crowd funded it and that was you know
the new thing to do that work so for the
next I'm not sure what we're gonna do
it's kind of like you can't kind of do
the same thing twice you know I mean why
I'm fine with well with with traditional
distributor with traditional sorry talk
about so much with traditional investors
you sort of you know they're going to
lose money probably and if they make
money great but if they do what's in the
long game so until the film's made money
it's hard to go back in the same person
to go hey by the way another tan Grande
what do you think another 30 grand it's
very very hard to do that because it
takes a lot of years from be profitable
so in the rare case you get hit but any
other thing is we're friendly with them
all it's not like they're like oh
where's our money but you know you don't
want to go back and try to tap them
again you want to go to the next round
so it that's why you kind of want to do
the same place twice until you can come
back with really really good news and we
finally have some profit for you cell
phone anything is hard because you burn
through your money you know quickly and
you picture while for that to build back
up and then with crowdfunding I think
you it's the same thing you go back to
that well the second time especially
before the first ones out I think it's
hard I think you can do it Gary Kings
doing his third crowdfunding campaign I
think it's more successful we do it in
small bursts to I know one guy was
filming in gorman who doesn't he's
always got a campaign going but they're
all like a thousand bucks two thousand
bucks and he just and he's raised lots
of money but he just keeps feeding and
people kind of keep double dipping
triple dipping because it's a small
that's one way of doing it but you know
it's like you have to wait it's like
it's like harvesting fruit you know yeah
I wait for the fruit to grow back with
the new film that we're putting the
other now small hours we're trying to go
to back to traditional investors again
but we're gonna try to hit different
ones and we're creating a trip going to
try to go for more money this time so
that's sort of how that works I think
it's really depend upon the film the
time it's being made and what you have
available to you at that time you'll
find a way you know that's that's the
way to go what are your thoughts on
credit cards I think investing look like
I suppose you have one that has no APR
for like a year and you're like you know
what I'm pretty sure I can pay this off
rapidly if I just put all this on it
really quickly and it'll be no problem I
think investment I think we're in credit
cards is did I don't want to I'm not
going to advise that because that's
really scary that said if I had a credit
card that had no interest for a year and
I knew I could make that money back in a
year with a resume in a certainty I
might not not do that but I think it's
always better to go with with positive
cash I have done this I have clothes an
IRA to fund a part of the film I have
done that so I it's like saying no the
whole thing is a you miss all the shots
you don't take will you you also do you
also don't have all the films you don't
make like how long you going to be dead
and here's your death here's forever
well they died with all this money yeah
but you could have made another film you
know those films are made over here
they're not made here so and I think you
know as I get older and takes me three
or four years to make a movie I get very
aware of time you know how many more
films do I have a form too old to lift
the camera before I get mocked so all
the levites furniture stock he said yeah
he's making you make it again I think
like I know these filmmakers out of New
York and they make it fun were a couple
of years and they they made their day
went on 16 they they raised a lot of
money and then he went six super 16 a
few years ago and then the next one for
like 40 grand they wanted to make
another one they didn't have access to
money just didn't have the they hadn't
gotten money from this yeah they had to
get my miss yet they were in a place
where didn't have money didn't when they
didn't want a crowd fund so they found a
way to make a film for a thousand bucks
they may shot on a 5d and one of the one
of them acted in it as a leading another
act of the New York plenty of the lead
and they went back to their hometown and
they shot in their parents restaurant
their parents played her parents and
these people that they knew and they
shot this very of the crew of like a
very small crew with you know lavell
ears and little mic pack and crew too
and they shot this thing for under a
thousand dollar and it's a really good
movie it's a really well done movies are
very well acted film they knew exactly
where where to bring in real actors when
we heard of like you know let people be
themselves using these locations that
they could control and they took good
time it's and they shot again these labs
use the zoom in a 5d and the film looks
and sounds great it's a really good
movie for a thousand bucks so I think
you often you just you find a way to do
it it's really how it works maybe their
next window crop under the next film
they'll do this but you kind of have to
unless you have a reliable source of
revenue or you have trust fund you
really have to kind of alternate how you
raise money for movies and you have to
kind of pick the right way of raising
money for that film or pick the film
based on the money you have access to at
that time
you